hey everybody welcome back to another
week of top five Skyrim mods of the week
him cam this is Seb and we're here to
show you months of that game which we
like to call Skyrim that game that we've
been playing for almost three and you
believe it's almost three years most
three years cam is extremely early this
morning isn't it it is it's like 5a okay
it's not for once maybe nine but it is
it is early it's early we got up early
everyday to bring you this show it's
true it's true and the mods this week
are freshest like spring herbs from the
edge of a mountain cliff where they're
great with a glisten of Jews stuff of
course that's eating off the Sun makes
them fresh set all right well let's get
to our super fresh mod number one
speaking of fresh Abbott's Kevin van
Owen I thought we were gonna pick me
freshest of the all the Kevin's he's
always ready for a fresh adventure he
always yeah uh when he's not shooting
some b-ball outside of the school he
does like or you know beheading people
outside of yeah that's why he's my life
back into school he never went to school
but what's that got to do with my number
one said nothing nothing at all so ever
know what I like said what's that dogs
you like dogs I love dogs that's a wolf
I love caravans better that's a fox in
it I don't like foxy so just bear with
me oh yeah you guys better our first mod
is dwell Maddog follower where and we
need to head into a dungeon to go find
him we are very nearly there okay he's
on the right-hand side along here
somewhere right there's keen eyes and
Geryon Wow
is that is he talking to us oh yeah I
think he is I think he has a human voice
as well all right dougie go kill the
spider pain dog oh well done boy we got
hurt a bit by that explosion a night
that electricity powers him up I only
just noticed that you can hear him yeah
yeah he's noisy as a machine yeah yeah
so where she sent this mod of her
Twitter weren't reserved uh yes I
believe we were I wait that's how we
knew this existed oh he is just adorable
mechanically speaking all the right
parts are in place yeah it's the engine
I love his mechanical tail with a little
clumsy core ah he's the best
yeah yes yeah and what's what's more is
he probably doesn't have a soul being a
yeah being a machine which means he's
the perfect companion for Kevin that's
very true
that's very true you summoned in cats
the perfect enemy so I did I mean I
totally a minute all right boy oh dear
cat is afraid of the dog it's perfect
why are they all running away cuz they
hate dogs oh god oh god you killed him
so hard his tail was left in play hills
that is just awful we went over here
come on doggy yes
I'm a killer yes he kiss me finishes him
off you've stun he kills oh man is the
ultimate combo feel stunning oh yeah
good boy
delicious there is one extra as well cam
what's that which is that he does
technically have a bigger brother what
only available in console come on
amazing how about we added ah there he
is and here is pop shock he's got a WD
g3 here's the voice of a lady
hahahaha no you're a mechanical dog we
are not one of the same kind we can just
leave pup shark there to guard our a
horde of cool kindig after these cat
corpses don't don't eat them don't now
come on I can't promise that don't eat
them cam what's what's that sound I have
no idea serve is it the dog no dogs
eating I think the dogs playing music
what what's going on I believe this is
music from that film the you endless
story a story that ends eventually the
very long tail so cam it is this is mod
number two is very chess team or this
way very chesty mod this mod is called
neverending story
orin orin is the name of that necklace
that is around kevin's neck now I'm
gonna be honest to yourself yeah I have
never seen neverending story which
really hurt no I have a couple of like
giants like black holes in my film
watching and not that many but a few
like Bigfoot's and one of them is this
the cover of the book that the child
reads of which the neverending story is
based in has that symbol on the front
okay it's called Oran and it's a
powerful symbol that allows him to
create whatever he wishes well apart
from obviously giving you the buff of
being able to grow on all wishes that
you could ever want ever kevin has no
wishes other than death there are all
more enemies I've ever ending battle
never-ending battles is exactly what
he'd wish yeah well you can have it
Kevin with Oren on top of that adjusted
or an enchantment
2:55 health magic and stamina boost
added resist fire frost shock and magic
magnitude 50 percent added fortify
alchemy and smithing at 100% because you
know wishing and building thing you know
it makes it makes us good as smithy
so all we need to do now now that we've
got Orrin is we need to get some kind of
Lee rabbit new mod that gives us a
Falkor right yeah I don't even know who
falconry no he's the giant Flying Dog
yeah well I mean he's a lot dragon but
sure he can be he could be a dog it's a
luxurious ride on the back of him go
yeah yeah where is he is he in this mod
no I wish he was
rabbits are really hard to hunt you know
that yeah why don't you wish for him to
be in your sights
I have happen wish hard got ahold Orin
and go I wish to kill this fish this
rabbit was dead no I didn't he didn't
wish hard enough cam I wish it was dead
by my own arrow
now yes it works it does totally works
wishing came true I wish that I wish
this deer was dead by my arrow come on
Josh
of way led that shot too much died come
on I wish there was less it Archer this
version of the mod is an updated version
of one taken from Nexus it does some
fixes and rebalancing and everything but
if you want to check out the original
it's also on Nexus as well and it gives
a few other details on the history and
lore of aura but if you like neverending
story like I like neverending story and
like cams never seen neverending story
then this is definitely a mod you want
to check and if you have never seen it
fear not you can still wear it get the
buffs and just be your armor on top
huzzah huzzah all right guys welcome to
mod number 3 which this week is dawn of
Skyrim the collection now said this is
like a collection of city overhauls
right yet a worm Whiterun and we are we
can see there are some subtle changes
and there will be suing all the major
holds I think in in Skyrim but they're
not they're all like lore friendly right
that's the key though the main thing
about this collection of mods is that
they improve the immersion right and
that sounds a little bizarre but they
make them more lore friendly than
vanilla the idea being that say for
example we are here in Whiterun it is
meant to be the trade capital of Skyrim
okay so why says the author postulates
the author are there not more trade
based things here in the city so what
we've got if you look over to the right
here we've got two new vendors just sort
of dotted around has 136 and treats this
one selling bottles of some sort
yeah right but just the general feel of
it is making it a bit more like a trade
cattle of Skyrim so not only is it
aesthetically overhauled you've actually
got new people that you can trade with
on top of that their new banners the
whole thing looks a little bit more
immersive
can I stick I take you can you can take
you'll probably end up in fights we know
that but over here at the entrance as
well as just having some you know nice
bunting to celebrate a trade that
outpost is new and
some kind of trade based thing for the
East Stand pyre east empire training
company so said no we're in wind hell
yeah it also had a subtle overhaul the
main thing I've seen so far is more
lanterns yes it's called the lantern
overhaul ah makes sense it makes sense
an adventure in light now this is a the
Nordic and done Merrick City overhaul
and that this is taken from on an earth
for example added bores as well as the
idea is that like there are tons there
are tons of overhauls that you can have
and a lot of them do some really extreme
stuff these are meant to be subtle like
they're not huge huge rearrangements of
cities and towns remember when we did
the industrial overhaul of Windhelm
freeze yeah remember and that was a
massive difference big chimney stacks
and everything I and I really like that
yeah yes this one's just making it more
Nordic and unmarried gotcha gotcha so
these are all quite subtle if you want
to play through Skyrim again say for
example do a complete rerun of the game
this would be a good one to have all the
way through yeah plus it's very very low
taxing on your system and we've only
shown Windhelm here and Whiterun before
but there's also rift in Markarth and
solitude all included in this mod
exactly you want to check them out
download it do it do it now well I mean
once we're done
yeah what's the rest of show first
all right step time for mod number four
which this week is called shield slam
yeah now I like a good shield yeah I
also like shoving a shield in someone's
face Kevin does as well he does it all
the time I've seen him yeah and fact
there it's a great way to stun your
enemy but I imagine understand that this
mod yeah improves your shield slam
somewhat the thing that I always felt
with Kevin Wright is that when he's got
a shield and he doesn't often use a
shield but when he does have one it
doesn't really represent the strength of
his arm which is to say absurd he also
hates carts yeah but can't even use his
arm he was worth through that day that
was all in the crotch look how look how
strong his crotch is only his arm could
represent that kind of strength so said
let's see what the vanilla shield bash
does okay I see no it's like a tap it's
a hey friend it stuns him take that okay
well Kevin's pretty strong so sometimes
it results in death that one done and
then hurt able to do power bash whoa
that was cool how strong he is he's like
oh God well he said it doesn't always
give you the POW I'm wondering if it
depends on who you find taking right but
you can go and use a console commands to
set the power damage of shield slam all
right so we're if it'll and launch them
any further but it will kill them okay
even harder oh wow that kind of oh sorry
k9 well I certainly made a more powerful
say but no one shots them yeah that's
pretty cool doesn't see been launching
them as far so no perhaps it's something
that you want to set to less than 100%
so that you get the launch without the
death perhaps yeah well I think your
dad's is only because it's on Kevin's
arms oh for sure so you can choose
whether you want the shield slam to be
something that one hits people or if you
want to use it more as a defensive tool
saying and there's too many folks here
shield slam to send them flying
all right step time for mod number five
the final mod the user voted mod of s1
and it is Thunder child epic shouts and
immersion glad you guys chose this one I
thought this is a cool mod so bird give
us the lowdown well we arrived here in
high Hrothgar d basically the way this
mod works is it suggests that for every
shout that we've learned in the vanilla
game yeah
there's a reimagining like a
reinterpreting of those words so for
example force balance push for a fus ro
dah will push someone over as you know
so a tiny bird it's a tiny bird sorry
exclusively found in high froth guard
okay the most delicious of all the birds
so for every vanilla shout there is an
alternate version the idea being that if
we were to meditate here okay we could
learn the alternate ways of understand
these words and let's meditate yeah now
I'm pushing button search all that oh
you did it successfully accessible
meditation this is why the barking of
dogs amazing new insights into the voice
so the other thing that we can do now is
we can learn them second and third words
by performing quests and met it and
continuing our meditation as well
there's a pair of HD gray beard robes if
we want them nice and there's three new
abilities that come with this as well
the storm crown which is shout cooldown
is removed when you enter elite combat
thundering echoes the first shout you
use in combat has no cooldown add way of
peace shouts have a greatly reduced
cooldown out of combat and OH
Cameron's gone support the monastery
with your gold yes we have lots of that
so that should be fine shout to the
heavens once a day can do carry coins
fire to the doors of hike Hrothgar all
right well let's do that first I see
fire it's green fire ah I feel pain real
pain ah I didn't even come close to
hitting him run run
well when Sprint equips oh crap okay I
did it I'm exhausted
what do I win treats gifts meetings to
the SEC first and second words all right
let's do it
successful what do I win so quite a few
actually arcane helix Armageddon
alyssia's love I love alyssia's love the
wife of sure Alyssia symbolizes the
unbreakable bonds of love and mutual
trust well I'm afraid it's time to be my
partner
I guess we're in love now this is the
worst love ever your thumb reaches out
to the stars calling down the fires of
heaven upon your hapless enemies oh dear
oh dear this is not going to go well for
you or me oh that's sweet I wonder if
he's like that forever statue army the
Terracotta Army I'll make my own yeah he
looks pissed
Oh huh Oh quick turn them again haha Wow
oh yeah not a lot I can do though so
that's pretty cool giving you a brand
new shout for every vanilla shout you've
already got in your inventory and what's
more you can't even hack that mod apart
you've got to actually do the quests in
order to get every single shout so uh
cam why don't you come and rejoin me now
and we can blow some things up Oh serb
canine is being hugely helpful today but
I think the only one thing we can do
definitely really show them how much we
care all right canine canine you know
what you need to do well he will need to
do something nibble on that chicken
before the work does oh there we go
I was just in the nick of time F that
wolf
he must have quick toast just extremely
well trained I think it was the thing
that made it work so well yeah I almost
feel like almost feeling we should keep
canine with a straw
crushed oh no - good
he was too good a 9-2 effectivity yeah
chickens well maybe we should wait we
should bring him back oh yeah week he
was pretty great you pretty great he
would be a great lights
long-term companion yeah he's got
everything Kevin needs yeah loyalty
loyalty Oh social for death and my old
mechanical hearts it's kind of AI real
really yeah
no Serb um this that this was a really
good fun show I enjoyed those mods there
were some fine selections um
now we've actually got some questions
and comments from from the youtubes and
the game spots so uh and I believe one
or two from Twitter's as well well let's
get straight to them so why'd you want
to take it away the first the first
comment well first things first
last week I asked you guys if anyone had
seen or knew of or owned a place in real
life that was inspired and altered by
Skyrim IRL skyrim i RL we did get a
couple of comments back but only like
one or two so I'm gonna hold off for
another week
can we show those just in case some more
come in do send those through tweet them
to a compressor over at Ready Steady Go
because I want to see him so next week
next week we'll show you what we got so
the first one from Nikko do you think
anyone has made a real mod for skyrim
make the houses look like they are in
real life and have people in everyday
clothes so basically the opposite of
last week's question ok so bringing real
life to Skyrim yes to turn Skyrim into a
modern day because we did play that one
mod remember that turned sky rental
horror game oh yeah that was good that
wasn't that was very weird
all that was weird wasn't it yeah it was
kind of like him it was kind of like
that game which name I forgot the one
yes how did you know I'm here how did
you know I then that is we're good
friends okay the one that's in your cell
at least you which is a great game yeah
okay a question so joseph duncan now
says i want the gallery of armors to
replace the armors of the guards and
their cities yes we're really good they
was last week's mods and we are with all
the different hold armors and some of
them were fantastic your request isn't
out of the question like there aren't
anything mods that you can you can
totally do that so maybe a quiet request
a desperate plea in fact to the mod
author of Gallery of armors if you could
make it so that it replaces all the
maple just if very happy yes and me and
can and me and the next question Karen -
turn - yes does anybody know the mod
they are using to add
six-two the branches and foliage we
haven't added any mods actually yes we
have we laughter we have lush trees and
grass mushroom trees and grass okay yeah
so if you go back to realize the more
slightly only physics we have readied
was boob physics uh that was a I don't
even want to tell you about it was a
dark day it broke my mind a dark wub Li
day in our fast we fatigue or a jiggly
day yeah there was a mod that I added
lush trees and grass which we added to
show off you know the great graphics of
sky when we put our new PC together if
you go back and watch that episode I did
post up a list of everything that we
used it's a process hungry mod yeah yeah
and actually in its vanilla of what
sorry in its default version
it makes the game look really weird um
so make sure you add the vanilla trees
to get it looking like that got you but
that's the one that we use yes good all
right final question from Rama Thorin is
less of a question more just a statement
and they say that chicken was the ball
it was I assume he's talking about the
golden chicken last bit separate it was
golden chickens the worst thing ever the
mod itself was deceptive the deception
in the opposite of what I wanted to do
I've ever my otherwise would have just
been stripe called the golden chicken at
least ramathorn liked it enough Rama
thought it was the balls I don't know if
he means the balls is ending right yeah
the ball yeah as a lateral ball actual
ball yeah yeah the worst whatever uh
yeah if it was what you thought
it definitely wasn't my favorite no
wasn't my favorite either definitely use
better mods than that you know what I'm
speaking of using better mods you guys
want to tell us which better Morsi use
next week ah you can do that via the
medium of voting and straw polls so sab
next week we have 3 mods up for the vote
not mod number one to choose isn't
Doomhammer Doomhammer
for Doomhammer do hammer the eyes of
youth played hearthstone or any familiar
with the Warcraft universe they all know
do hammer so you can vote for that
choice number one and there's the night
of Molag wow that's pretty good yeah
he's a mighty mighty character with lots
of mighty mighty loot to be had on him
cool uh and so the the vote last week
you know we like to put in the second
place mod vote yeah
second place was an even the draw an
actual drawer so this week and this week
only I'm gonna put them both back what
four choices for Chile mad Sam mad are
you crazy
everything's gone to hell I can't even
care that hi hi Carly a problem
apparently the mod page can either wear
it gave us a hundred and one percent
votes oh yeah it's true we had 25 25 and
51 yep
take that I'm no mathematician but
that's not correct numbers doesn't add
up to a hundred at 101 Kevin's weld it
all makes so we've also got van nord
armor and yeah mirai the girl with the
dragon hearts so make sure if you want
to choose one of those you go to
tinyurl.com forward slash ready sir be
bla absolutely and if you have anything
to say to us at all we love all your
feedback or comments we got loads over
Twitter so keep doing that you can tweet
me at camp for us Rob I'll do my best to
reply I've been a bit crap lately cuz
I'm busy I'm away and doing stuff get
back on it now I always guarantee if you
tweet me this week I will reply
guaranteed guarantees so just ask him
questions like question ask me love
question how do I find love where are
you going with your life cam I don't
know but I will I will tell you that
over Twitter and you can do the same to
say peas at ready saving yeah I don't
probably have more better responses or
better more better more but as English
is more better than mine it's too cool
yeah send us all your pictures as well
everything but all your pictures you
know all of them not those ones and
especially not those ones to yourself
your pictures yes not on I don't want to
see them and you could also use a
hashtag which is a GS Skyrim disk oh
great
well sab it's been a pleasure as always
it's great to be back on this two weeks
in a row is first note on that in a
while God what about you forget what I'm
not rid of me now I'm back who else is
back and like just like back street yeah
alright great
alright we'll see you next week
you